oh man oh man we're bad just looking at
Lady Gaga in a bikini this old guy oh he
phone stolen two civilians see what
you're looking at I don't give a [ __ ]
oh yeah oh is it on Instagram is it
internet um it's a internet wasn't
Instagram she's got a butt on her she
does have a bush got a fuck-shit that
critter has [ __ ] the credits got a
[ __ ] and you know we caught she
that's a dump I can't stand those words
they need her Jimmy Burke Easter said
she's got a real [ __ ] huh she's got a
dumpster on her house like dude don't
say that you know don't say don't equate
it with poo real dump
but uh she don't like guys that talk
like that anyways yeah I don't like
anyone who talks like that
like I get done I don't want people to
figure out who I'm talking about so I
get done doing this class and the guy go
that you know he's talking this girl he
goes dude I went what's up you know you
guys only time a girl they hooked up
with it's like I've never been there
yeah I've never been there and he goes
you know he's this short little dude
whatever it he goes dude oh it what's up
he goes I went oh you hooked up with
egos more than that more than that and
then he's used to most guys being like
oh wow dang man what do you what's more
yeah so you guys had sex what more did
you do he's all yeah yeah I killed it
man like you killed or he's like no no I
just like get out of here man I hate
that [ __ ] I one more I had my friend one
time who's never like this but he just
kind of went yeah she's good a good time
was a good time you know runs a
tremendous operation yeah this mafia
yeah just impressive she barely knew me
and she just she dove on my dick capped
off in her mouth and that was it
CatDog CatDog yeah I loved it was he an
extra in the cerrado who's [ __ ] dove
I managed to say that was the best
she runs a tremendous operation you know
what's funny go from there it's so funny
he's so relaxed it's like he knows he's
being funny
yeah you know I mean at the end of the
day she jumped down today I didn't even
know her very well I mean you know at
the end of the end then I gapped off in
her mouth I felt rude but you know I'm
not gonna stop a kid from doing what she
wants to do anyway it's just not so
great he's the best just the great have
top kept up and a mouth is his wife is
pregnant and and she was we were eating
we were at the comedy cell you've humble
eyes to be a bit yeah we're at the ultra
and he's gone Jess the tits on you
look at her tits oh she finally got yeah
you can't see it there's some so what
you're working with she's like let it
rule yeah she's pregnant she's like I'm
not doing that it's like me and and and
[ __ ] Jimmy Burke no she's got
cleavage for Christ's sake um you know
she had sex with me twice today what am
I gonna do Jesus animal and everyone's
why we'd be talking about something
totally dissed hear him Bahama go shout
all he ever said at this yeah four sets
in a night right that's what they do in
New York you do force that stuff and
with the Comedy Cellar now I think there
are four rooms
I saw three of them amazing oh and by
the way they're packed we're really
Sunday yeah they're packed it's like a
connoisseur but in New York yeah so you
can do that and on a weekend you're
making a hundred hundred fifty bucks
about a spot so you're making much
longer than with five hundred bucks why
so much because they can well you could
do that in LA if you if you could if you
do at the Comedy Store right you could
do that if you go on those shows that
the main you don't get paid though that
the main room you do yeah yeah yeah I'm
saying if you did if you did like you
know well yeah you could only really
maybe do - yeah it's not set up the way
New York the hat trick you go main room
sure oh are girlie room I could if I
wanted to I could do a lot I could do if
I wanted to in LA I could probably do
four sets a night right you could do
main room better indoor water and then
dual a factory and then and The Improv
then cap it off the du Kappa Kappa Kappa
The Improv yeah okay I could do that but
you know I was talking to some
but I won't yeah I'm 51 yeah I've been
there on you've been there I was talking
to this comedian in Orlando and he lives
in LA and he was saying how tough it is
for him to give up here but in New York
he was getting more spots he's like it's
better out there yes I think I think
it's different I was able to do five
sets a night in New York when I was
coming up he couldn't you do that here
for yet ha ha I sound good but the drama
it's it's very tough there you just
think and also at stage it was hard in
LA especially when you're starting out
when I was younger even after with TV
credits I couldn't get stage time yeah
you gotta get past the common story I
got it but there was a time where I was
doing a lot of sets but um New York is
built for that New York is built all
young I say yeah and of walks to four
set tonight he wall that's nice yeah and
every crowd is different and every crowd
is from a different country I mean it
you know and now with the remember when
we went to the Comedy Cellar remember
that around the corner one type live
music has amazing they turned that into
a comedy club because they can't keep it
empty because we'll keep it not and
that's right next to Comedy Cellar right
and then we saw Tom papa right he was
there and then dev was doing a set down
there yep yep yeah that's the original
seller and then they have the famous
table right which is the table where
when you when you walk into the olive
tree cafe you got SD who is the manager
she kind of decides who goes on then you
you'll see Chris Rock you'll see Dave
Chappelle you'll see Jay Leno you'll see
literally I mean bill burr soon dumped
it off you'll see all those all those
those those old did those bad mother the
whole school was sitting around who've
done it on the highest level and they're
all talking louis c.k and they're all
just hanging out still there no I didn't
see him this time took a break but that
table is famous that not sure is where
they all just hang around it's
incredibly Comedy Store though back stay
that the in like the green room there's
pretty freakin yeah nobody ever used to
be even now and then also by the now
they have that bar in the back just for
the comic yeah that's pretty dope yeah
we're saying teen get Chris Rock row
yes you Marc Maron yeah yesterday
Russell Peters gets out of his portion
and I just I love him he's such a good
guy Russell and but I'm like you're
talking about a comic that place to the
Staples Center Russell Pete do you know
that is huge internationally for
internationally as big as yeah yeah like
millions and millions of millions people
what about us it's just funny it's just
you you see these people that couldn't
be bigger they're a basically comedy
stock star mr. Chappelle shot is special
there yeah belly room
yeah and that crazy yeah Lucy cash shot
a special there yeah yeah you know I'm
saying yeah yeah it's amazing
Russell's been doing a lot of jiu-jitsu
he's always doing Jitsu oh it's true my
thing is I see Russell always want to
talk about Tommy you gonna stop that
fighting you know yeah I know fine I'll
talk comedy then he just takes over in
the film out fighting everybody wants to
be what they're not yeah I know that's
how it goes man I tried I did some
boxing yesterday and decided to go to uh
do go you know I faked one way go down
keep my head down and get get in got
punched in the [ __ ] top of my head
that didn't feel good for you yeah I was
good I worked out with your boy Opry
Marcus this morning oh really
Boyd's in shape yes he is I set him up
with Glen my charger so we did MIT so I
minute on I would go to the bag when
he'd be on MIT's and vice versa did
probably 40 minutes of that and then we
did a circuit after that boys in shape
though he's a different shape but he's
in shape different shape different shape
he's definitely rolling yeah well it's
funny um here's my question this is such
a stupid question
don't answer this ours hands oh no what
what what did you say what oh you
talking about fighting for real it's
funny too because you always talk about
how the you know with everybody talking
like all of us all of us civilians
sparring or something and the guy I was
moving around with is a very big guy and
he played he fought Golden Gloves I
think one in Boston played semi-pro
hockey a real athlete and takes it easy
that doesn't count
takes it easy you say semi-pro yeah it
doesn't count doesn't matter just for me
he's just I'll doesn't count though I
play bass one in high schools today he
kind of hit me lightly on my cranium
like just lightly he's not
around it went Bob because I tried this
thing and I went oh [ __ ] that that
really hurt my cranium it hurt my head
pretty now if you're sick you're
sparring and you get and somebody like
just steps into it and really hit that
head gear does absolutely nothing
nothing it's like all right zero don't
don't spar I'm not sure anyways dude how
about I file I watch the push how about
that I Ryo was I right i watch trailer
again on it god still doesn't look good
even Joker's the sixth ear while it
brian says freakin good so we played it
was amazing I don't give any spoilers
late again say again it was amazing it's
amazing that guy's a real [ __ ] there
but we were like he's so hard a guy
really laughing so hard how he was like
just you know what I know these these
are supposed to be vegetarian but
they're not there's beef and I'm just
put these flags a new disease it's these
little calculating boobs and he goes
really yeah just put them in he's trying
to impress everyone yeah because they're
a little move compliant you are how
comply you're willing to sacrifice
but he was at the end of the day turned
out to be a good man because he no
spoilers I'm not sprouts were alerts
that the endings amazing that means the
best part endings ending threw me for a
loop the ending I was like what the [ __ ]
what these people is now you kids how
many two minutes
it's crazy 72 minutes you can see who
somebody is that's a brilliant show i I
would have made it past that you know so
the way they just saw who's gonna be
compliant is they have people come in
and sit out in all these chairs and
there's four actors and they would get
up and sit down
for no reason and then they bring out of
about him they bring in regular people
and the road people were told nothing
and but they saw the group standing up
and sitting down and sounding the bell
they see them all in order doing it
we're not asking any questions
yeah I wouldn't be that guy I do to kick
me out right away [ __ ] yes thank you and
that's what happens
but don't what person does do that to
don't tell any more but it's a I'll tell
you this if you want to learn how to act
if you want to learn how to be an actor
watch that show watch how people behave
real people behave in a crisis yeah it's
amazing how some how little their face
does for sure but I was just like oh
[ __ ] and then because there's a dead guy
in it
and
they're to build this dummy musk us I
don't don't tell them don't tell no well
that's not giving away no there's a
there's a dummy there's a dead guy in it
but it's not a real guy playing a dead
guy yeah but the that I mean tell me
that they made is that incredible or
what it must have cost hundreds of
thousands not to feel real yes yes it's
nuts
the show is amazing that shows me you're
right yeah it's better mind blowing
it's [ __ ] mind blowing and here's my
good but this is this isn't giving
anything away but they did they kind of
like show you how like the power of
people the power of suggestion yeah so
in the beginning it's not the show it's
just like a little flavor like a little
trailer show what this guy does he has a
TV show in England I guess if I can pull
this off in America but in England he
does it and there's this guy working in
coffee shop again these are actors they
have an actor come in with a baby and
she's pushing the cart and the guy who's
a bar barista right at this coffee shop
they call him dough hey listen this is
detective blah blah blah and he sounds
it's an actor saying his distinctive
boba did a woman just walk in in her
mid-20s dressed as this and he's like
yes he goes she's a known pedophile and
has kidnapped that baby I want you to do
this and the guy without any questions
takes this later a baby stole a school
baby stroller baby off like what defines
you an idea first of all how devious
somebody could be if they wanted to
steal a child you know I mean there's so
many things where it's like what I mean
the whole thing's [ __ ] nuts the whole
thing is like the whole thing is
astonishing nuts right it's just
astonishing like it it was great here's
my question though
I wonder if without giving much away or
anything way I wonder if when you're
seen on that show to do one thing or the
other
as in whether or not or whether or not
yeah oh the ladies is that ruin you're
like that couldn't really [ __ ] you up
for that room that's why I couldn't do
it here I think I'm going to play by
different rules that's why I think oh
you could never shoot that but would you
hire somebody who did the opposite of
what they were supposed to do in that I
mean I don't know yeah it could it could
have stopped your life for sure I can't
believe those people signed off on
that's what I mean and are they because
I would have said you know
aramis I'm like not not sign up I look
like [ __ ] they probably I'm sorry
largest [ __ ] before him
well remember they signed on to be on a
show beforehand and they didn't know
that that was the show you do kid so you
signed away your [ __ ]
yeah it's it's very I thought the same
thing I go oh my god there's terrible
people yes who decide to do that yeah
well we've given up way a lot but just
watch it because that's for to all this
if you want to watch the movie not be
surprised we should do a little spoiler
before him can we just that's a spoiler
okay yeah but either way that's crazy
yeah nuts I don't think we would comply
with it they would have made it past
that it makes me nervous when I was a
younger guy I would have when you're
young and you're you're confused and
you're trying to do see the main thing
about that is that they all were trying
to do what was right you know what I
don't think so I disagree I don't think
they're doing it right they were there
under the notion that they needed to get
this done to network to improve in life
well there you go I saw your friend
sites on being a good person doing
what's right then doing what you think's
gonna help your career out that's the
way it's set up you say oh I need this I
better do this I'm trying to press
that's why there listen that guy can
ambition that with a mission behind you
I mean oh this guy's a good guy it
wouldn't work with guys like us it would
work if it was everyone in this room and
will sasso entirely unexpected role game
if it was my friend yeah and they were
and I'm like okay why I know he's a good
guy I know what he stands for if they're
saying this I'm not seeing this the
right something's going on here then I
could be talked into it if it's five
strange adults like I said five strange
odd goat this ain't working I'm smart
new guys there's no way I'm doing that's
right you're [ __ ] I there's no way I
don't know they already know as an adult
like I I hosted this show and they I
remember I could have easily gone along
with this sort of humiliation of this
girl and in the middle of the shoot I
just I just went nothing's wrong it was
a whole group of people there was a
whole I was in front of Ryan Seacrest
was there I was in front of oh let's
call it four
hundred people all kind of on the same
was it like that was my key situation I
was making for really good TV because
this girl was having a breakdown and I
stopped I stopped it and said we can die
in the middle of the shooting I go I'm
stopping this [ __ ]
I'm not gonna be part of this humiliate
humiliated this girl she doing she was
asking for money and she was clearly not
mentally stable was she's acting she was
she turned out she had been found
herself a lot of times on these reality
shows one breast was smaller than the
other and she wanted to get him fixed
and it was very humility and she was
asking money for that yes it's very
humiliating and they were all laughing
at her and it was really good TV it was
very traumatic and I been ice and I
stand this is not IIIi didn't mean to
say that Ryan Seacrest was there I don't
know if he was there that day and I'm
not putting him I'm not saying he was
part of this I'm saying he was producing
a show that I haven't have been involved
in so I don't want to in this production
company I don't want him he had nothing
to do yeah and by the way I had very
good experience with him so I don't want
to I don't want to I'm not throwing him
under the bus here there's a larger
point I'm making is that I I just went
oh this is wrong this is not Diesel
feels not part of common decency and I
stopped it and I and I said I'm not this
is not I'm not gonna be part of this TV
this night is not happening on my
watching I'm not allowing this I'm not
allowing a person who's already a
wounded animal a wounded horse somebody
who's obviously not mentally highlighted
I'm not gonna [ __ ] I'm not making
money I was making a lot of money I'm
not making money off of somebody no in
fact the next day the Friday prior like
you know what we're all in the moment
Brian was right they did the next day
they they brought they said thank you
and I said yeah I mean and I knew the
people I was working with were good
people it's just you get care you get
caught up and very entertaining yeah
it's like remember uh American Idol they
would always have these people that were
total losers yeah my favorite part and
they would make fun of my favorite
that's different that's different well
they're putting themselves in that
position but it was also they knew it
and also they were living this false
sense of reality where they thought they
were legit singers yeah then they go
there and you have experts go that was
terrible like you guys are kidding you
guys are crazy
yeah that was the best part and Maya she
lost that also is that yes there there's
room
that but sometimes those people are on
the spectrum or they're just they're
just they just this one girl sang and
she was with her her grandparents both
her parents had died and her
grandparents were there and they didn't
even know how to deal and she started to
cry because she was humiliated and and
her I remember her grandfather who was
this older guy he didn't know what to do
in he went you know these are these were
they were from some part of the country
where they didn't have a lot of money
and they're in Hollywood and it's very
intently good and it's very very you
feel very small here's the thing big
here's the thing why I think it's
different because those people will
dedicate their lives becoming the naree
Underwood well I know parents go you're
it you're it and then when they get them
they go oh my god this isn't it then
they move on with their lives
otherwise if they don't have that and I
don't see in Cuba then they don't really
humiliating they humiliate them if they
go that was awful get out of it one more
song and then you know that we're
telling you it's just not there they go
you guys know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about they're like oh we don't
yeah and then that's when they might get
it this girl had been a shower singer
and her grandparents loved her so much
that American Idol and she got up and
sang and then Simon was mean you know
who you know who doesn't do that the
voice which is probably why they have
bigger ratings are the voice they don't
show any shitty thing the voice makes me
cry because when sometimes sing see I
don't like it when getting laid around I
like it I like it when they're picking
team stuff like that when they do the
bat the bat sing off like get the foot
what is yeah I don't like that I like
when they turn to when I go to I give me
goosebumps just a minute somebody
started singing it's like dad I'll be
like turn turn turn play one of those
things I love that chick is the minute
the minute like you'll hear they're
literally sing avert like a like a child
with to a world away yeah and you're
like man and those people know those
that's the other thing you know those
[ __ ] were on the voice they
know music goddamnit
and then but then some of them whoa Adam
Levine is [ __ ] brilliant listen I
used to hate him because he's really
good-looking other stuffs got his
awesome tattoos I think yeah guys
whatever and I heard him say I told you
I could happen in my lungs college but
he [ __ ] my buddy's girl in her name
was Jane his next album album was called
songs about Jane it was just coincidence
or what but it's awesome dared he can
I was like I have so much respect have
you heard his new stuff
no it's rare I buy albums I bought that
album really I celebrate that man I'm
gonna wanna hear again I promise here it
is fashion I'll get it I'll get it
I love it here's the fastest assistant
yeah quickest coach turn switch turns
[Music]
it's gotta be Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
his brother jump around them titties
[Music]
he's a singer dude
[Applause]
[Music]
who's that guy was a tattoos on a fool
oh it's Arabic also the army of Enya
[Music]
Jesus how cool is this damn Arab [ __ ]
yeah that's where you realize we're all
human it's weird when you realize we all
like [ __ ] TV we all like human
excellence and that song is like how we
all react all of us and they're all
they're all basically we're all the same
it's [ __ ] beautiful all right one
love everybody one love Philippine I
stop that - stop that chicken hey hey
hey don't ever don't ah don't ever no
one love - the voice one love and be
dead serious God I will quit this show
right now if you ever ever do that no no
I'm not saying that I'm not saying like
no hey hey let's not do that
I'm saying if you ever get serious again
we're watching the voice and go one love
- no no this all I'm saying love it no
no that's how I'm saying this I just
want to say this and don't what weirds
what your well watch my words you don't
be wherever none of that again no I go
we're in the middle of listen people see
you know one love no no I this is all I
wanted to say I know what you know what
you're hanging out with the wrong people
I haven't seen you a while no people
maybe I misspoke this is all I'm trying
to say and don't and this is all I'm
trying to say and I get I get that I'm
trying to say that what now we'll be
careful cuz I will walk off I don't know
now hold on that easy man no I don't
need tools I know I'm just only tools
just exhale no don't need you be all
right let me express myself I just want
to say this Captain Planet I want to say
this about it about the voice be my 51
year old gay friend right and I mean
this and I this is no big deal I just
want to say a big deal when I see the
voice like that I just want to say it
I'm saying will redeem yourself here I
truly in my heart deep down okay I true
little here if not because you're
getting you know I tell you about - no
I'm not I'm not gonna tear up I'm just
gonna say that I mean this I just I'm
your half mass in your pants now okay
did everybody listening every one of you
whether you're in jail wherever you are
no idea Liz no sir I love you as much as
I love my own mother
is that what you meant by one love one
love one love you saw the air people say
boys Filipino people thinking I was like
we're all we all react the same to music
and I was like and chin is Korean in a
sings country and the point is that it
brings you over [ __ ] I feel sick
oh maybe it that I wear like this no no
all I mean is we share this we share the
same cuz I know you too well and then
when you got sir said one love now I
just may feel sick I just mean we all
share the same heart there's a lot more
love in this world
I'm just saying we all share the same
you know our hearts are connected with
an invisible line called the voice
that's all I'm saying voice changing
lies meant that's all it is now that
Filipino guy might have to see that guy
no have you seen I think it was the
first winner of the voice or maybe
season 3 well when I was I was doing
Tebow's charity event and we had a
dinner a private dinner and he got out
of guitar and it was the single most
beautiful tune that guy was sick you saw
him - yes I was there when I bombed
remember and he was went up to bring him
up I went up to him and I go you were
amazing and he goes thank you man sorry
about you that's what I've ever hears he
goes tough crowd for you man I'm sorry
about that I was like don't worry about
me best I've ever heard no no what hey
hey green person in person I actually
think I agree with you sir and a
good-looking look familiar but what's up
any of these guys look familiar the
guitars I know he's not a good talk he
seems ridiculous whew one will find me
time after time the voice time whatever
type in voice guitar you know what dude
ever again he was sick he's a black
gentleman this guy yes yes
Xavier Cologne I downloaded song in
iTunes he's sick Oh chin you think in
sing
[Music]
goosebumps
the only where's that hat too
[Music]
I'm gonna show me the kids I started
crying me too
one love one love boys one that [ __ ]
gets me emotional Jesus
CeeLo look at see lo how are they not
treating as he's being dramatic his TV
dudes you wait you can't argue with that
boys have to turn that one so so you
know he's so phenomenally like a phenom
all not steelo ain't turnin now he's got
a way laughs Rascal Flatts brought him
on the Road Dogg cuz you aw you know the
lead singer of Rascal Flatts
yeah they at Tim asked him goes who's
the best singer you know and he said
this guy that's the lead singer of
Rascal Flatts you [ __ ] yeah Rascal
Flatts are great I don't know they're
he's a killer
hey turn you [ __ ] let's go Adam Levine
looking rough back in the day there you
go
hold on hey tell me tell me if you're
feeling this be tell me feeling this
don't you got a huge erection that I can
deal with that yeah I do
she needs to go on The Voice dude no
dude dude to dude bro bro chin
hang on for a long time Cameron leave a
[ __ ] man hey that's Alyssa's the voice a
little cocky though you might be right
the [ __ ] back here tomorrow at the
transit I think because we're part of
the show yeah the chances of me getting
on would be pretty high
how do you feel do you feel confident
that you would be able no dude there's
so much better
they're so good soprano chin the problem
well you'd have to practice it's a
confidence thing but you if you're
especially if you have a special sound a
different sound that's still that's
throw what the hold on sir a special
sound spent dude you're a giant Korean
that seems country hope you might weigh
in I will be waiting
how are you dressed like this chin and
then I'm in the backcountry I'm in dude
when's the next tryouts dude why don't
we go well I'm in the background that
should be your tattoo I should be a
tattoo one love huh and then have the
circle of life like no I want to get the
boys he was under weird contract so he
hasn't been able to like get out of it
that's why you haven't heard from no
real dude I'm telling he's saying that
and a Rascal Flatts song in person I
felt like crying I love him
I had delicious pasta in front of me I
love how like that man said one love and
I sucked his [ __ ] alone Xavier :
Kavya : Wow
I don't know what he's doing now but
that boy needs to get you know it does
man I hope he the boys did he win or
something he won he won bro you can buy
that on iTunes come on man let's get
this [ __ ] out there where is he
it'sit'sit's contract stuff brother
after the voice please sign a universal
look record put on some weight though
definitely put on some weight you look
so he looks like Ruben no you can't do
that I want American Idol no weight
putting on well done job is left to time
he's released albums of two on three
thousand sixteen sixteen all dude let's
go to it see what he's doing mate see if
it's on YouTube chin hey by the way
making money as a musician nowadays
Apple music and spotify good luck with
that it's all merchandise touring that's
why Bieber makes bubble bike bro and
cutting again it's worse it's like we do
correct B um although gravity hit it you
know what you know I'm feeling chin
how's your haterade over there
my what I feel like you're hating on
this man hell no Keith your archrival
oh what's going down and right I
appreciate Talent I love B what notes
would you give them for this book we
shouldn't have yes this is his new video
it's the only video you can get you
shouldn't have any acting abysus you've
just lost the best thing you'll ever
have that's got an English accent I'm
not mad at that it's about to drop this
gravity on your left on man let's get
serious
oh I'm not mad he's back in shape - he
looks hydrated no quality though yeah
I'm not crazy about this video I like
the song though red panty night you play
this
oh do you hook up with the barista man
you can't blame the man that's a hot
little barista God living no same pose
this song about him sinking down the
breeze be nice if she met some hose if
she makes a mean dick a Chino I'll sing
no Clos who is all be feeling this song
chair anything you do better 74 better
it but it'll slaughter you think yeah
top song yeah is it what else is is that
it on this man he's brilliant but yeah
you know I gotta get something get the
people going yeah now hey hey chin yeah
have you heard you to Leon bridges no
River Leon bridges river that River
Han let's stick with this real quick
before we bring up this mainstream
[ __ ] guy let's stick with our boy
cologne real quick do you have anything
else chin or not there's a bunch of
different don't wanna stop bro but
there's a lot of them are older four
years ago houses how many how many views
is you get clicked on true colors I'll
click on true colors you know this long
hi Tessa hi Gracie
four thousand views not great so much
haven't seems like is reloaded by
someone else having a great great day
just a nice guy to send you this song is
one of your favorite songs and it's one
of my favorite songs too so I hope you
like okay I think he's talking to small
kid there's kids all this [ __ ] song it
Timmy's thing
you can you play this chin learn it
learn it I've never tried playing it
learn I'll turn it into a country song
all right hey just just for comparison
no he's great click on the trolls Justin
Timberlake singing it with Anna Kendrick
have you heard that
no the trolls movie get your [ __ ]
mine right this is when there's this one
they were getting ready to release the
trolls do you know Anna Kendrick the
actor yeah I was amaze Downton and I
think she's sex hich perfect meet -
there's some about her little mouth on
talent I call her mousy sexy she's mouth
you sex mouth sex
you're right get her some cheese you
think just to make us is how when watch
this Brown he's been doing music to dick
out keep your hand warm he's been doing
music this is a guy who knows plays
guitar by the way
don't be discouraged you like my boy
Xavier did better
well yeah but just a surprise beast
super beast Neil Ben Bruno trains in huh
yeah Anna Kendrick just a little mousy
little mousy Oh mousetrap
what's that I Swiss cheese that's right
I'm a dick
that's right salami that's right what's
that salami dick like cheese but no I my
dick the salami that I put cheese on tip
mousetrap mousetrap whoops whoops mouthy
mouse all right chin that has 24 million
well I'll say something I believe that's
because that resonates with the human
soul believe in God there I said it
no it's not I gotta pee you [ __ ]
atheist we back all right man we back
let's do this bro you gotta hey man we
got that the wilder I mean the Joshua
Parker fight this weekend drives three
days bringing down we don't have to talk
about that no what do you think um I
don't know enough about Parker I know
he's no joke obviously and I know to be
a great fight I am surprised if he wins
I was thinking more along the lines that
I think I think Joshua is 250 right or
is he too soon be lighter now give me a
lighter incoming lighter but you know
how much did Dante Wilder way when he
fought Ortiz about two 18 to 14 to 14
I'm like that doesn't that played a
major factor of those two or two box
well Wilder try to kill me talk about a
different fight now be anthing justice
fight Parker Saturday night
I think huge test nine one jump the
water I think then aunty Josh water
aren't fighting next they're not no no
matter what no why for contract reasons
there's some other stuff I can't
announce that I've been told but so it
doesn't make you don't talk about the
puffs like that you'd fight this weekend
you don't like Joseph Parker at the
Joshua is a huge test huge fight that's
like that's like talking about empty
Joshua wall or before he fought Ortiz
that's a [ __ ] nightmare fight night
so this is a nightmare five so Joshua
Joseph toughest fight since Dylan well
I'm you know what
Dylan why it was a
fight for anthe Joshua wladimir
klitschko off the tough fight yeah it
[ __ ] Joseph Parker's right up there
man
he's just smaller but we'll see how much
how much smaller is he significantly
really yeah well it's 247 actually
different build though yeah different
bill you'll see one time oh yeah yeah
different that waking me and your ass
and legs as opposed to here he is great
cardio is faster
Joshua hits like a Mack truck oh he's
got a hat on
he's got that that board that's Samoan
or Maori head great guy great time in
the interview ears tonight with him and
then how about below the belt first my
first time an actual Showtime network TV
tomorrow night not a bad spot 7 p.m. a
bad spot at 6 a 7 p.m. but the Joseph
Park in a reason there's a point so I go
out to Vegas to interview Joshua Joseph
Parker cuz he trained that of Vegas he
flies in from New Zealand to drink when
he's in camp here and we talked whatever
have a great time is a calm a let's do
dinner something then we go in this card
is this giant Royals Royce I'm like
you're not a Royals Royce guy you say
Royals one more time please say rolls
one love no one more Oh al-qaeda band
today cuz you said hey look at me you
would I'd never seen you more serious
and I felt sick to my stomach so let's
carry on believe in God and I and
universal love
I really wouldn't delay makes a lot of
people and actors are like acting
changes lives
Delia's for sure relax I thought you
just doing music saves that an acting
teacher said look seeing like this can
change lives not only in here I'll relax
this is the best I've got a scene he
goes look look
scene like this can change lives not
just in here out there oh good
and every because they just watch here
you here this year yeah wow wow it's and
it was always a lot of times the women
they would do that that's great
yeah I don't know man either way that
was a rental car not his and it was his
friends his coach's son was driving it
so as a rolls-royce rolls-royce
rolls-royce Royals was no royal and yeah
that's I said you called rolls-royce
I say Boyle's say oh thank you
rolls-royce he [ __ ] up the story cuz
positive on that either way amazing
fight I think I think it's a better
fight and once people think let's move
on you get some kind of engine yeah how
about a Facebook losing 80 billion worth
of shares after that scandal that
they're collecting data it'll come back
that'll do it Cambridge it's gonna come
back yeah I mean that that's a
fluctuation in the market you know
eighty billion oh that's that's not
really um we just go no biggie no it's
not it'll come back I don't know if it's
that plain and simple it's just like
they're fine well everybody's you
everybody is not gonna stop using
Facebook what it means that we're gonna
use it different they have to make
technological changes they have to make
system systemic which they're doing have
you seen that have you seen the crowd
yeah which they're doing yeah they said
their window before this breach happened
but it's one of those things like Apple
product so when Apple's stock like you
talk to economists they're like Apple
products are to amassed in everything
that we use that for it to go down but
not 80 billion so like for instance
snapchat when they had that horrible
promo where they like who'd rather hit
Rihanna or Chris Brown and Rihanna saw
it and went on social media went [ __ ]
snapchat their stock dropped how much
ain't coming back
Wow one person we're in a different it's
just no longer was cool well I feel like
Facebook is so everybody uses it and
it's almost indispensable at this point
right it's almost like Google like
everybody's on Facebook we all use it
for business now we all use it for news
now that's why it's such a big deal I'm
sure no they're not going anywhere but
it's definitely a hit yeah I think that
the bigger question the bigger thing
that raises we can Tesla Tesla drop well
you [ __ ] cuz they were doing
those automatic cars and not two people
died over
right new Tesla well not yes Tesla has
automatic cars in self drivers you
people brought the Ober self driver that
killed somebody in Tempe so Tesla just
had this was this morning bringing that
up chin it's either is it
uber or Tesla because I know they were
trying to you know it's over and do
automatic I know live over in a
driverless car and uber there was
somebody in the car from over but it was
driverless and it killed a woman in
Tempe so there it is yeah and now
there's been two right so why why would
that make I only read one either way
Google Tesla stock drop these can these
things can affect too but the but what
I'm saying is that so much in this
technology is this is I'm feeling you
know a meshed in what we're doing um
that it just becomes you know Wow there
you go
fatal crash of a Model X in Northern
California driving system and the
tehsils are having issues but don't you
get a crack a few eggs to make an omelet
when you transfer there's gonna be some
casualties go back to that picture dude
that's not oh no I would have put my car
in self-drive mode why yeah I'd wait
till they figure to me - I'm not doing I
did it yesterday I'm not doing it again
now you do it a lot right yeah only you
only in a stop-and-go traffic I don't do
it when I'm going 65 miles no I don't
trust it yeah it's too crazy man you're
like that once I'm that one guy died
because it's all the Sun glare yeah well
no it saw it saw the the white sheeting
of a semi and thought it was the sky and
just kept going
yeah well it's like today I was watching
I forget what it was but this guy who
was like he's well known for being like
making slide like those water slides
yeah and they so many people have said
hey man you got heard in the slide I got
hurt in the slide so the investigated 20
reports hey I got [ __ ] up on the slide
you got [ __ ] up on the slide they
interview him he goes it's the safest
water slide in the world and just
covered everything well little boy went
on it got six habitate who's just had
ten
so now they're saying that guy you know
covered this up he's going to he's going
away for a long last time they said
there's charging with murder if you know
rightfully so cuz he covered up and all
these people got hurt not to mention
employees then when they said they fix
it they put employees on it and had one
employee time he was like I got [ __ ]
up on that thing I told them and they
didn't have the credentials to build it
they didn't have the actual credentials
algin earring credentials yeah I like
take a real scumbag lost his [ __ ] head
like little boy a ten year old I have a
ten year old
oh yeah that kind of stuff is terrible
the [ __ ] point is this is that you
are selling your your data is out there
and it's being sold without you knowing
about it they know everything about you
so the question is how do we solve that
problem how do you how are you able to
keep your data your privacy is dead how
do we get it back that's the biggest
question here come on how do we get it
back that's the gun issue so many guns
out there do you ever get it back I
don't know will you they go you go you
go down his water slide by a hard pass
for me I just think it's disaster I
don't know I don't know I guess don't
wait for a long one it's just a sad
story
yeah guns are the same way you're right
you got that many guns out there I don't
know I don't know them all your ears out
there sometimes you just don't I don't
know the answer to
there's smarter minds than us trying to
figure out the answers I like the hope
yeah especially with the gun issues than
than with the privacy issues this thing
might be changing because kids are taken
to the streets and you know III told you
I read that it's just a couple statistic
about guns what is it a lot of gun
violence is either suicides handguns
suicide and then you have that the
craziest statistic that's gone on for
decades is half the homicide half the
homicides by gun are black on black and
they only make up 12% of the population
now think about that in on NPR I was
like what it was crazy
this is the number soon of the thirty
holding my death so much of it is by by
suicide so
the actual numbers of assault weapons
you know are not that they when it
happens it's so horrific because it's so
easy to kill people well that's on an
average day ninety-six Americans are
killed with guns there are nearly there
when that's thousand homicides a year
yeah for every one person killed with
guns two more are injured all right yeah
two percent black men are 13 times more
likely than white men to be shot and
killed with guns ham yeah a lot of it is
is neighborhoods black and brown
homicide victims are much more plentiful
than waiting homicide victims would bike
on like by fall it's black on black
crime yes yes five percent I believe of
all so so last year this this black
woman was talking about this she was
saying that 16 black men were killed by
cops last year but but 95% of all
violence homicide you know deaths were
black on black because it's gang [ __ ]
it's gang [ __ ] in Chicago it's gang [ __ ]
in you know it's and it's in the
neighborhoods that's the truth so the
whole thing is [ __ ] when you get into
this [ __ ] when you get into it and you
get into it with Second Amendment guys
and stuff like that who are
knowledgeable you're in a you're in a
forest of conversations here there's a
lot to be talked about the bigger
question is you and I are talking about
this is okay you got you you know you're
not allowed to have machine guns hand
grenades and anti-aircraft weaponry
should your tanks should citizenry be
allowed to buy easily a an ar-15 a
modified ar-15 a modified m16 basically
which is incredibly lethal with a
30-round clip that can be replaced in
five seconds I don't know man is that
can we have that conversation is it is
it fair to at least say is that too much
lethality is that a conversation we're
allowed to have you know I don't know
you know I don't know I don't know I
don't know and I know people out there
you guys are all talking about the fact
that you know you want you want your gun
so you can protect against government
tyranny doesn't hold water anymore
because the government has technology
that a lot that laughs at your [ __ ] Oh a
drone old piece you don't have a
I'm sorry drop that yeah it laughs at it
so we have to come up with a different
reason with me drones I liked Jim
Jefferies did the stand of thing and he
goes here's the reason you guys like
guns I get it not a great answer but
just be honest it's cuz I [ __ ] like
them
I mean I'll work with you on that
everybody but I'm not into that no but
that's that's the honest trees and think
people want their guns no safe I mean I
want my gun in my house because I don't
I don't want to be without a gun if
somebody's coming in with you I don't
like them I'd like to have a gun frankly
carrying it in this [ __ ] world where
somebody might open up with a gun so at
least I can shoot back that's the way I
think okay I get it
and I understand that certain gun laws
have worked in places like Australia and
stuff we're a very different country
we're just a [ __ ] diverse country
with so many different points of view
and I don't know how you get I don't
think you're gonna get people in Alabama
and Louisiana to get to give their guns
up you're just not I don't see it I
don't see it happening to different
kinds of points of view but but you and
I know we have a conversation about it
can we we all know here's the bottom
line we all know we don't want spree
shooters does everybody agree we don't
want high schoolers and younger kids
getting shot in school by by by the you
know but it doesn't we all know that
nobody I don't care if you're NRA I
don't know so let's have a discussion
yeah
what's the answer I don't know preaching
to the choir here but right and I don't
know but but we should have a
conversation when the [ __ ]
politicians are bought off by the NRA
and they're not even allowed to raise it
we all go back to our [ __ ] places
what is yet Jim all right fertility
clinic in Cleveland this is really sad
actually so four thousand eggs that were
in a freezer you know they're gonna be
there their kids and everything else
they're they're holding them there for
now in the for women freeze eggs yeah
cuz you know I want to get older we
can't have babies so this clinic I guess
someone purposely turned off the the
alarm system that shows what whenever
the temperature you know rises a little
person cuz it they had an issue at this
hospital where they had to refill the
nitrogen tanks because something was
wrong with their system so someone just
didn't want to deal with it turned it
off and 4,000 the eggs died holy [ __ ]
so what happened so 950 families that
did that are losing their
do they soothe us they have Isis crude
but no money in the world you know I
have a certain number of eggs as a woman
so that's gone you know it's it's really
sad got a tub of bourbon you would sue
the piss out of that clinic but I wonder
if you sign off like not Irish Mike well
no because if you're doing it they're
responsible yeah I wonder what the legal
action that's the only responsive but
[ __ ] and that shit's gonna happen right
a horse a freezer somewhere is gonna
fail of course he's gonna fail
eventually I think this is only the
second time but it's happened beforehand
but this is actually done like you was
gone on purpose is how someone did this
addictively how about these lately how
about that cryogenic you know when
people freeze their bodies so they can
be rebar brought back one of those
things fail and apparently apparently
when that happens you become a
gelatinous mass it's just a it's just a
red gelatin nightmare well when you
unfreeze of course it's been frozen for
we've been dead for about 20 years now
when that freezer breaks down that
tissue literally looks like red soup and
people think they're gonna be able to
bring let's let's every freeze this
sorry let's just gathers see yeah
we're so unfamous they look like a giant
red popsicle but all freeze you yeah
yeah some people who whose what
celebrities have been frozen I thought
not human not Walt Disney he was not
really sure there's some that have right
cryogenically frozen Aurora gonna be a
whole lot of bro science here let's see
yeah that dr. James Bedford the Ted
Williams it looks like it declare Joanne
Gair Thomas K Donaldson okay well no
Dora Kent is that as Ted Williams yep
there you go there Williams Jerry leaf
it's Ted's
cousin alright so not like what and Walt
Disney you're right it's a rumor B
what's that it's a rumor Disney frozen
himself yes really piece
SiC if it wasn't he came back to life
yeah Forest Lawn I've been there for a
couple funerals for young people - very
sad a couple friends of mine are buried
in Forest Lawn if it would save a sock
Tiffany let's not bring this show down
like that it was just like man oh come
on man
sometimes people die oh yeah Jim all
right this is actually a little funnier
kinda funnier Corey Feldman it's [ __ ]
up he's on social media guys such a what
happened he posted that he was stat like
he was stabbed by some strangers three
people and one person came out open his
car door and stabbed him okay he says it
as you can see the hoax
well it gets to them it seems like it's
a hoax because he goes I'm in the
hospital I was attacked tonight a man
opened my door and stabbed me with
something please say prayers for us
thank God it was only myself and my
security in the car yeah when he Cory
mm-hmm yeah keep going he was well
security was distracted with a guy a car
pulled up and attacked me I'm okay then
he goes the LAPD is currently
investigating cases an attempted
homicide
I had a mounting threats about you know
how he was like saying all the stuff
about pedophilia all that in Hollywood
so you own the whistle so people yeah
he's saying that people are after him so
he thinks this is probably why it
happened but then the LAPD came and said
no well there's a witness saying that
someone did open the door and did a
stabbing motion but he was never stabbed
like he has no lacerations or puncture
wounds anything yeah he's trying to get
he's trying to get some sort of
publicity he when I think of Corey
Feldman I think of the worst Hollywood
on has to offer really I think he lost
boys and I know and I think of I think
of what what being a young Hollywood kid
actor in a person in effect he's have
you ever never seen his performance
speaking of great performances please
Google his performance at the Triple A
baseball game with the alien dancers and
I've seen it and I need to see it again
I have seen it I've seen it twice and
I'm asking the city that's the way some
people movie ends cuz I can't get enough
so and now this is his chance to get
back in the line there you go - it's
amazing Jin you you're better
he's the worst he would kill this guy
we get the family in the back do you
think it's doing on purpose these
debtors I'm not sure why he's dressed
like Michael Jackson
[Music]
[Music]
why did this college let him do this man
I had the whole thing so more to find
[Music]
at least he's really committed Jesus
why is he dressed like Michael Jackson
why is he doing here Michael Jackson
booze
[Music]
dude how about the girls in the back
what do you think their issues are
alright they're just there for the
Paycheck Maroney is going bad feeling
when I see him boys then I brought watch
it twice yeah that was a great movie but
everything else he just wanted I
generally sucks in my opinion he said
I'm from his capital a trying to
capitalize on this pedophilia I know and
now pretending to be stabbed he's just a
huge [ __ ] publicity hound and a liar
it's just it's not working out even the
media is like you can't Alex the mean is
not really picking even this up like all
right whatever I know you can tell he's
lying yeah yeah well it's like
desperation dude you're such a liar
super desperate yep did you ever work
with him be I never worked with him
never did nothing no but he is you ever
run into many parties or anything no
never
oh nothing really I met him I met him
we're at high places but he's I know but
you weirdo like I met him you never met
him no you have no I met him in person I
was very very briefly very where at
I had a [ __ ] party what's with the
[ __ ] temple kind of party nothing
dude I can't talk like a theme party
can't he said he's I don't know what
you're even asked was like an 80s party
it's an 80s party where we were dressed
like vampires all right there I said oh
like Lost Boys yes like The Lost Boys
and would you guys do well I was the I
was I was what's called the sucka Fant
and I had to lie there like a look like
dressed like a girl and they all suck my
blood oh wow yeah but you know okay and
they sank their fun if you hum you know
the bangs in I don't know maybe picture
on Lost Boys - no he's just a strange
cat Jesus it's a sad story yeah what
else you got Jen did you guys see the
Ronda Rousey interviews the last two saw
Hilah I just saw the one with my Golic
that one yeah she's just not won any
fans with this is she what she don't
know just play free it's pretty short so
what's the
first take bad - with Max Kellerman I
didn't see it max - my favorite so let
me see I'll just play show Brian the
first one okay let's go back and start
with when you knew from the the MMA when
you were done there when you said when
you knew in your mind I'm not gonna
fight anymore I never said that ah so
there is a possibility that you could go
back in time there's a possibility that
I can go back in time that's a question
to me go back in time go in and fight go
back in the Octagon I do not have the
ability to go back in time now
no would you fight again I don't know
yeah she gets very very defensive well
you're not allowed to ask them I make
questions I've never seen this one what
they didn't play in that preview that
max Keller make that bigger for me you
was I said that you were a woman who
through your fighting when it when you
became such a big deal shoots man now
it's like the earth stops spinning on
its axis and that's the part I chose to
focus on after your losses dumped me in
the UFC yeah why does everyone talking
about oh my god she lost is she over all
these kind of things when you achieved
such Heights that one lost the whole
world stopped and noticed that a mess
was kind of think a backhanded clump
notice negative backlash to you after
the loss people you must be aware in the
MMA world there was a lot of talk well
she was overrated she was this she was
that and my point of view was at the
time and remains that you achieved that
she walked off it's not almost no one
wins forever everyone suffers setbacks
but there seemed to be like an unusual
amount of negative pushback after your
loss did you did you not experience that
exit experience a lot of people who
quote some people that are really just
afraid to state their own opinion do you
think it's my opinion that no that's not
my opinion she's not winning anyway
achieved amazing things I was an M
remain a big fan of your fighting and of
you that's not that's not me saying some
people meaning me that is me saying I
read and heard from others and defended
you
well thank you for defending me I
appreciate that okay Ron doubt so it's
just a himself any favors that was about
it with Rhonda to though so the obscene
Maxon of UFC makes much left at all so
imagine if Cannella came on in max went
hey he would never do this to her but
ever ever do this to a boxer if you went
hey Canelo so we saw the first test you
know it was barely over with clenbuterol
he says Mexican tacos the second one was
15 times higher do you want to talk lat
how do you feel about that a lot of
people say you're on steroids a lot of
people think you're cheating yeah I
don't know if I agree with it what do
you think the people saying you're
cheating yeah you would never let Rhonda
got mad because max was asking a
question he knew the answer to so so I
can tell you what the answer is I mean
so in other words if I ask that question
what I'm really trying to get Ronald to
do is say you know what I was a heel I
didn't win well I didn't with Miesha
Tate when I didn't shake her hand huge
[ __ ] people went Wow including me
including me I did not appreciate it as
a fan but you know it's weird about that
B and I don't think Mac's saying this
this is your own deal with this stuff
laughter Rhonda beat Misha people a lot
of people respect her more after that
because of what Misha said about her mom
I didn't hear what she said about our
moms so I don't know exactly so this is
your own deal this isn't Matt but let me
keep God also her star was never bigger
than after me yes okay and but but but
but and I and I disagree with that for
another reason but I hear I'm saying
number wise yes number 1 Mary please yes
van wise never be so - what happens what
you can do that right you can be the
heel and I will like you I like that's
just Rhonda right now until you exactly
so that already sets the stage then the
way she came after Holly home before she
beat her was not graceful it was really
it was kind of a nasty
weird right nothing so when you do that
and you lose because what you're
behaving like actually is a bully
because you're not being graceful in
victory you're being a bully and so I
think when that happens I don't care
what anybody says that's that's how I
felt and I you know I like Rhonda but
when I saw that I was like it didn't
make me feel good and I not surprised in
the least that the fans and Americans
were like that out they came after CIO
that's what happened one more things say
when she lost unlike a lot of other
people like Conor McGregor she just
disappeared
bingo right that's the most of stuff I
don't somewhat I don't agree with you
with but with that that's the biggest
thing is after a loss what you can't do
is go medium medium medium you know yes
give me all the interviews wants fine
and dandy yes yes I'm the best ever and
all you put me on ring cover on this on
this and then you lose you go I'm not
doing this right people go whoa whoa
whoa whoa right hold on strong losing
this ride together
nope I'm not doing this I'm not talking
you guys anymore uh what the [ __ ] man
and the people go oh [ __ ] that right and
then they go yes and then you disappear
now you're doing this medias not
supposed to ask about MMA at all I don't
know if you know that no you're not
supposed to talk about fighting with her
at all I didn't so when they bring it
wouldn't and I would never ask that
question that max I mean maybe because I
know Rhonda but I be I don't think
there's any good answer there I mean I
you're putting Ron about this and I
think it's mismanagement with rot what
Rhonda's team is doing but they should
go listen obviously not ruins a fan you
need to address this head-on you
avoiding it and shutting down this MMA
it's making it worse right what you do
is look I had a hell of Korea hell of a
ride Holly Holm is a damn good fighter
man and I had no business fighting a man
in years I was in the right mind frame
I'm on to bigger better things I'm WV
now I've always wanted to do this I'm
looking forward to it that lost suck but
here we are now
you guys go okay cool man and then move
on Zach but when you go don't do this or
not now the only the only publicity
you've gotten out of all this press is
negative now would because yep you've
done so much great stuff I couldn't
agree more [ __ ] on it with this and then
what do all the outlets pick up this
yeah when she's not she's not a bad
person
she's not on me but she is a pioneer she
is a pioneer she's on the Mount Rushmore
but whoever's managing her they're just
doing such a shitty job of it and this
her manager same as the rocks but being
wrong [ __ ] miss so all I would I
would say listen we need to do a media
scrum and you're gonna [ __ ] attack
this head-on yeah and anything you ask
you don't get defensive don't be mean
just go it's Holly Holm and multi-world
Wilson the only person that at the time
- I I was I was upset I felt like you
know I I wasn't prepared on some issues
with my camp when my trainer I was going
through this I was going through this
and come off as human and everyone go I
get that and then we'd leave it alone
but what you're doing now is people go
oh look the superstar and she's wounded
what's up let's keep poking let's keep
poking the bear and you're gonna deal
with this your entire career and it's
overshadowing herb she's moving on she
has the potential be the biggest WB star
of all time but she's not handling it
rugby she doesn't have anybody like you
to tell her that and I'm not the guy for
the job
no that's why my guess is the Rhonda
listen to very few people and if you
start talking to her that way especially
her management that she doesn't know her
trust very much she buys trust issues
with human beings right so my feeling is
that was someone like Rhonda she's gonna
get defensive immediately probably
because that's how she grew up but she's
very defensive and not she put the shell
around it's worked this far but now
immediate doesn't work like it doesn't
work she just needs she needs somebody
who the responsibility ultimately lies
with her because she's got to be willing
to listen to it you can't do is go
I don't want talking about it's never
happened well no - hold on that was a
huge a moment in time let's talk about
if it I'm not even even on the same
wavelength as far as Fame and find like
that you want talking about my losses
let's do it man do you want to do when
you were let's knocked out so you can
tell you about my show coming up if I go
on radio shows they bring it up man your
last five 2014
trash Brown like [ __ ] me tear will turn
it into a child I'm like getting punched
in the face and turn it no sir my set
yeah first half an hour my set is about
how I got here have you seen that not
have it let's talk about that you turn
it into a strength 100% and and I think
that I think that's just falls on her
management we're all up to Rhonda was
built this way Ron is built as a
winner winner man winner winner chicken
dinner that girl if you get in a race
even though she has bad knees she will
do whatever it takes to get to that
finish line and probably beat you by any
means necessary so you have a team
around that goes let's do this let's
show my softer side cuz it's there what
she listened oh you know her that's not
you haven't talked to him forever I'm
not sure I'm not sure but but what she
should do knowing Hollywood she should
do is watch these interviews and go
that's not the message I want to do man
or her man's right this is the prom I
bet when she gets back her team's going
can you believe that
what the [ __ ] iron when they should be
on roof that's not what we came here to
do sack because now the only thing
everyone's picking up is that and the
message was you being at WrestleMania
SummerSlam or other [ __ ] it's called
that was the message now the message is
all this I agree yep yeah I've had like
on that rants there but it just again I
keep saying that's the ultimate
responsibility lies with Ronda that
you've got it you got to be able to
navigate this if you can't navigate the
press be you've you've been around
fighters dude I'm dealing with on below
the belt well you know I talked very
sensitive I don't I I give and it's the
worst part about my gig is when I have
to give prediction on fights I'll say
this guy has this weakness this guy has
this strength this this what happened I
cannot make this stuff up but I talk
about the current situation of the
fighters go on some fighters you all get
diem what the [ __ ] man
how can you top dude yeah what do you
want me to do mitt so for her
that's a fighter's mentality yeah I said
that to you one time because I've been
around how about how about one time
remember remember when we're not when I
I'm not gonna say who it is or what it
was when I went I went dark on someone
on a show super dark and I was like
ideally try with me when I get all mean
and nasty and you went no pull up cut
this yeah this is Fox Days chin Bryan is
no no you're not I'm not letting you go
out like that yeah I'm telling you
Brendan that's not what you want outside
you wait you wait you're not you're not
that guy now you've what's happening is
is you've been put in a corner and you
feel disrespected and you're lashing out
that's not you though that's not I know
that's not you and I took ten minutes on
it you're right Brian thank God you did
that yes because I would have looked so
bad and you came back and you made it a
joke and it was perfect correct because
see it cuz I could tell you were already
you were your feelings were hurt yes and
as a fighter and as an athlete you're
you're like you're one of those guys you
you what if I give you like five minutes
of breathing room you're fine but - what
part of what got you there is a
competitor you or any and I've said this
to you with other fighters have been
around what gets fighters you're on your
own in that octagon it takes a specific
personality different [ __ ] people to
get into an octagon and fight and and it
it requires a lot of self belief and the
way you talk about yourself and stuff
and and I've never met a more sensitive
group of people and if you attack their
honor their commitment their whatever it
might be you're gonna hear it but they
stored away to store it away it's very
very aren't you'll read something even
when I'm fighting even now a little bit
I try to get away from
but someone say something you click and
you're like an elephant hope he said
that and then when you're on these media
tours and they're like there's that guy
mmm yeah nope not him yep nope not doing
that yeah no I can see it with you
because I could see your nose starts to
flare a little bit and your face gets
flushed and I go [ __ ] the big man
nothing not anymore I really don't know
not anymore not anymore you're so savvy
now but when you were younger and you
were in trouble and those balloons were
fresh man you were fighting you were
fighting and you had to believe in
yourself super fortunate where I have
good people around me but I'm also open
minded I know if Ryan saying this if
role Ian's saying this whoever saying
this each or my team saying this I
Madeline I'm on the right mind yeah
that's what I think maybe Rhonda doesn't
do enough of she probably doesn't
actually listen to people closest to her
friend Ron team around right she may not
asked she may not even ask their honest
opinion and you know you and I the most
important thing about friendship is it
like we're honest with each other we're
[ __ ] honest with each other you know
the person who tried the most honest
with her sir is her husband Travis brown
where you know I don't know what Travis
thinks of me drastic good guy yeah
grabs a good dude so maybe you know I
don't you know Travis one of the best
you know as far as ripping promos on the
Mike's of a phenomenal [ __ ] fighter
and I don't know where he's at as far as
entertainment business savvy I have no
idea probably not his cup of tea maybe
maybe he can see I don't know or maybe
they're both just the fighter mentality
and he's like now [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
which it isn't gonna be good at the end
of the road
yeah man he's yeah [ __ ] they're going
down it's just an you need you need to
dip and I'm not talking about her
specifically someone on our team they
need to implement someone to control
this not control her you just you gotta
you gotta you know painted a different
picture come you're doing this I get it
man that sucks I understand exact we're
going through I would try this way
though
because this is what Hollywood's picking
up and also you won't be in movies that
ain't gonna get you there because
everyone shuts down when they see that
it makes everyone on the edge or single
oh yes that's right that's right yeah
it's it's an interesting thing man it's
like um you just part of like learning
how to navigate that negative energy is
so important when you're a celebrity on
that level [ __ ] you know and if you
can't do it it will eat you up Sean Penn
one two it was a really punch is
erroneous Sean Penn when do you ever see
Sean Penn go through that phase where he
was punching photographers yeah oh yeah
Bieber what do these youngest [ __ ] do
you want the same thing you go clowns
and went through it because when he did
that el chapo interview America turned
on him oh this is a yeah but this is way
before when you I know that I'm saying
even now they turn him yeah they last
movie did yeah that's also because he
alcohol he's got his he's got his deep
vices he's a brilliant you see him on
wasn't he on that he's on man no no no
Stephen Colbert's yeah yeah hold on a
sec take a look at me out it was not a
happy as a guy guy in me he's a guy
rabbit he's on drugs
yeah he's brilliant I think he likes his
drugs I think he's he's on man in a
tractor not saying yes I turned that off
the parents I'm Stephen Colbert last
night the two-time Oscar winner was
promoting his new book and decided to
light up a cigarette
during the bizarre interview that I'm
doing well you you've inherited a little
of the ambien I had to take to get to
sleep after a red-eye last night you're
still a little bit on the ambien train
right now
okay I got a challenge for you I got uh
Jimmy Jimmy Carter I thought you might
so
Jimmy Carter is my guest on Friday Cobra
73 let's see if you can bring more
energy to this is not a wig yeah he's
let's see if you can bring a little more
energy than Jimmy Carter you're not
acting anymore in that interview you're
breaking a lot of people's hearts by
saying that why why don't you want to
act anymore this face I mean the
breaking hearts the plenty of people who
be thrilled
also humor that my god looks like yeah I
told you when I met him right well I
told this is a true story
I'm with John Leguizamo and we're having
I'll oh yeah we're having we're having
brownie leg is the best where I'm gonna
get him on the podcast please yeah your
one-man show yeah he's the best
John was a huge influence on me but we
were having breakfast at Chateau Marmont
and give me a have a pen I want to show
you something give me that pen and and
as we're talking a Philip Seymour
Hoffman car ahead hi Roy
here's the night he's the color yellow
Sean Penn is no this is Philip Seymour
Hoffman all week before he died Oh dad
it's kind of sad but he's one of my
favorite actors me too you never have
said oh yeah Phil Tarawa was just okay
in that movie you've never said that
he's great in everything team polish and
I are here for a while I got my hair oh
wow okay then then and I and I'm not
doing this for theatrical effect a guy
comes up and he's skinny I noticed one
thing he didn't have a butt and he had
and he just looked so Haggard we call
that mr. burns it's very very big sort
of a very big nose and I swear to God
him in my mind I said I said that looks
this guy looks like a [ __ ] 80 year
old Sean Penn who think I'm a leak at so
I've done he looked like it and then I
realized in and this sounds like a joke
but I realized that for about a minute
it was Sean Penn and he was so nice cuz
cuz John so nice John goes this is Brian
he's a stand-up comic and Sean Penn went
oh yeah yeah yeah I know I know you just
kind of cool have you seen it no I was
like oh [ __ ] it was nice and and then he
was
very nice and we talked he was such a
sweet guy but I just couldn't get over
how tired them how drawn if he can't
sleep done well he's got maybe can't
sleep yeah maybe whose drugs maybe just
can't sleep maybe maybe is writing so
many scripts maybe cocaine does that to
you I don't know if that's what it is
but either way I'm always amazed at how
many drugs there are in Hollywood among
celebrities like like the amount of
smoking the amount of boozing and the
amount of drugging because I'm with
super famous people is astonishing like
I have been astonished when it's all my
favorite actors yeah yeah he's an
amazing actor I have always loved him
me too he's as good as it gets he's just
dramatic look at him yeah a little weak
no no that's his hair Hammer Colbert
when you smoke that much all the time
though you're gonna have to stop
watching Colbert it's just a rant on
Trump every [ __ ] night now which I
love those talk shows but I can only
hand so much political she faces
shrinking he looks like a franchise
about French oh when I saw him when he's
dating Charlize Theron
Charlize was every bit as tall as when
he should heels I'm like that's a big
woman that's a big girl hey matumbo down
in the back and I looked down and I
thought was Danny DeVito but Sean Penn
yeah I spent some time with the show
he's a big south african beauty that
timepiece yes I say girl heard your
monster speaking of monsters uh-huh you
want to get this thing cracking
yeah I can see that happening that's a
crack into reference to the pressing the
Kraken yeah the water which means MIDI
no I got it I got it
see mom I don't know if you pick up
these to light in the ass she's got big
volume - I'm bringing champagne I'm
bigger than job you beat up Sean Penn
right now yeah now yeah yeah when he was
younger I'd be too and all he was in
your semen at close range
oh come on Burroughs thank you bring
bring up his arms and that clothes right
take a look at his body in that clothes
nice man could put some muscle on if he
wants you can put some semen his father
was a great Leo pen oh really
yep grew up in Malibu John grew up in
Malibu and okay did this is where I
loved him so much
this is what did you see the end of
this where he says this my father seeing
this movie men love the movie chum
[ __ ] Christopher Walken oh my god
this is a at close range one of my
favorite movies thirty-six son yep one
of my favorite movies how do we
ascertain shut pen I know but he was he
was Madonna said he was she he was my
true love [ __ ] please a man and Rodman
and Guy Ritchie no those guys meant
nothing and poor Sean's brother died
UNITA from an enlarged heart nothing
from cocaine what else you got chin
that's heartbreaking
yeah sure sure I loved Mary Stuart
Masterson right there I loved her so
much
let's get chin poor Brian jacked up this
Arlene I get all excited well this is
just a picture of Rudy Guiliani
wearing are those what else if earpods
there pause yeah he doesn't know how to
put them on Giuliani's he saw his father
get shaken down by the Mafia all the
time so it's just going viral cuz he
says they're like the opposite way
around
he thinks like in bluetooth I'm
surprised he never became ran for
president especially after September 11
yeah he changed he changed New York and
I was there for it and I remember when
he really live yep when he said I marry
he said if you are part of an organized
crime family in this city I am declaring
war on you and he watched them [ __ ] his
father up they used to shake his father
down at a grocery store oh that's why he
was yellow he saw his father become
humiliated he sons really should run
down did he change the game well they
set the Fulton fish market on fire the
Mafia set it on fire Fulton fish market
biggest fish mark in the world they
controlled all the fish they control
over prices they set it on fire
and then he said oh by the way you guys
own construction - yeah watch this we're
gonna start bidding and I'm gonna get
Chinese companies Japanese companies
especially in here and we're gonna get
this [ __ ] done in time and he cleaned
the [ __ ] city oh oh and then he also
said oh and by the way done some
research people that pissed on sidewalks
and do graffiti they also do other
crimes call quality of life crimes I'm
arresting you now so cops started
arresting that crime just went [ __ ]
what was badass
our balance if I change the game
surprises never got dealt with though by
the Mafia [ __ ] they no one's on
touchable they tribe you know same be
yeah but not in New York
they tried in New York he's Italian he's
part
you got to remember also the the unions
it's just the the New York police force
at that time things were already
changing there was so much pressure on
him you had the feds on off you that one
Giuliani what Giuliana was like he's
also brave his [ __ ] yeah they honours
like go [ __ ] yourself wat Giuliani was
if they had really old a mayor it would
have been it would have been you know
really Wow
yeah I'm surprised he's never ran for
president and they're also the Mafia I
didn't think he was gonna be able to do
it you know they were so glad but yeah
they were so entrenched yeah the only
and they've held on to his garbage and
they've got some other stuff but you
know he brought them to their knees man
he didn't Jesus yeah let's get you um
the first ever NFL male cheerleaders are
here I don't approve of the Los Angeles
Rams you're joking
I don't approve it's real
congratulations to our 2018 LA Rams nope
nope nope nope nope I don't want to why
is our society changing like this well
I'm all about eat oh my god all the
rights and all that [ __ ] kiss all
about you and your brother come on look
how happy is where right there the
bottom right he's doing that toss the
girls in there and stuff yeah well it's
hard where I imagine if there's an area
of those guys are real athletes they get
injured there they're just as athletic
play the little clay palm I just like
saying stuff
although these guys can move but you
have to be very gay right I mean don't
you have to or or no or your ladies make
you have all the hottest women in the
world you toss them in the air well I
guess it's straight as a bone there
they're all the way they were they're so
happy know what led to you wanting to
try out to be a cheerleader you know I
was at a Laker game the Wednesday prior
and I was like oh hold done halftime
second he's so good says nothing I kind
of love both of them yeah I'm into it on
various proteins I just thought why not
me like why can't I do this so I called
my friend Raquel and I asked her when
auditions were for the RAM would Rock
the Tulsa but hey but of course ado can
dance but of course it's the LA squad
that has it first but of all of it look
you know what I kind of love it I'm on
board look I'm not
I'm not mad at ya baby shake it he's
every bit as [ __ ] he's good
that motherfucker's a trained dancer
dancer but we hear those auditions that
Quentin was referring to this ever show
with the Dallas Cowboys trying to make
the cut they put them [ __ ] yeah if you
want to be you know cheerleader I
thought it was like they were male
tutors out there throwing girls in the
air and I thought you me all-male - now
he's a cheerleader isn't he's wearing
pom-poms a skirt though he's told me
that's messed up
I'd really respect him if he had a skirt
on you tell my transgender then I'm just
talking about cross-dressing well what
else you get - alright we were just
reading this a little while ago
something called interstitial which is a
brand-new human organ that's been
discovered yeah I mean the interests are
just now discovering just basically it
acts as a shock absorber yeah so they
say has something to do with cancer
right they said since they found this
they think they'll be able to figure out
a way why the cancer spreads the way it
does Wow
so obviously if they find that out then
they can find more stuff about how to
you know cure cancer but Luud filled
compartments research term interstitium
this combined I found beneath the skin
as well as lining that got lungs blood
vessels and muscles and join together to
form a network so you're just found it
no they thought it was a connective
tissue before well babe loma is that
well that's why when they were cut in
your back and cut through the fascia
they would remove the fasciae and it's a
huge problem because it's so important
for your loss yeah Jesus damn that's
cool man that's nuts right always
learning a man always learning Brennan
always bitchin fluid Phyllis you want
more I think we're good buddy it's
before we do it we gonna go easier
though something so hard I hit people
all right buddy how's the phone in b1
love well my buddy wanna love I'm
throwing love lots of love out Thursday
night Friday night Saturday night San
Jose improv sir I love it's gonna be one
love bro I love my brother I love it you
know you know you know
what's up April 12 13 14 West Palm Beach
improv I love it there are you sure it's
great right yeah I love it there and
after that is if that's not enough I go
right over to Boston I'm in love that
keeps on loving you from 1920-21 it
laughs Boston you'll take if you're
listening that's why I want you to lose
this won't you hold hands yeah have your
dick in one hand yeah your other hand on
your friend yeah and then I want with
your feet to get on the computer and go
to tak calm well you know what gets for
Brian and myself not only that like I
listen things are good I'm gonna be in
Denver the twenty six twenty seven
twenty eighth but there were selling
very well there I'm not worried about
that
the Colusa casino I just remembered I'm
there may 5th all bro now Colusa Cecina
but up there may 5th okay you're talking
so much 12 in Colusa a lot it's a lot 11
May it's a long way from now that's a
long ways but I just want to cry but
that's alright no there aren't so one
love one love t fat key calm for Brian
myself San Jose
I'm coming then end of April Calgary Yuk
Yuk's that just went on sale the show in
Bakersfield is sold I do do some defect
gay.com one love this is a fine kid we
love you guys we're out